show business is notoriously fickle some
actors are lucky enough to have careers
that last decades whereas
others struggle to capitalize on early
success if you're curious as to what
happened to the ones who fit in the
latter group keep watching to find out
robert duncan mcneil owes a lot to star
trek one of his most notable roles was
as starfleet cadet nicholas lecarno on
the next generation episode the first
duty he then became cocky helmsman tom
paris on voyager which would become his
defining role he would ultimately phase
acting out of his life and replace it
with directing a skill that he learned
over multiple trek series
on his first day shooting the voyager
pilot mcneil approached producer rick
berman and expressed interest in
directing an episode as soon as possible
he'd long wanted to direct but the shows
he'd acted in kept getting canceled so
instead of waiting around this time
he wanted a chance to direct during
voyager's first season he ultimately got
his chance with season three's
sacred ground and he would go on to
direct three more episodes of voyager
when that show ended he took a few small
acting roles and then transitioned to
full-time directing and producing with
his credits ranging from such shows as
the oc
chuck and blue bloods franco
zepharelli's 1968 version of romeo and
juliet was a huge hit at the time
and still endures as one of the best
shakespeare adaptations ever
it was especially notable for casting
actual teenagers as the title characters
with olivia hussey as juliet
and leonard whiting as romeo both earned
praise for their performances and were
considered future stars
hussey would indeed go on to have a
respectable career but whiting all but
vanished the actor became a victim of
typecasting
as he played a few romantic leads in
smaller movies before becoming jaded he
took a break from acting and tried his
hand at writing
painting a series of books and plays
that never got published he lived off of
film residuals and the odd voice acting
gig or art picture
interestingly enough in 2015 whiting and
hussey reunited on screen in social
suicide which was a bit of a social
media age retelling of romeo and juliet
despite concerns about typecasting
almost every actor who's played james
bond has gone on to have a solid career
outside of their work in espionage
george lasenby however is the exception
the australian actor played bond in
1969's on her majesty's secret service
only to outright vanish from hollywood
after the movie hit theaters
however he regrets nothing lazenby was a
model by trade with no acting experience
who bluffed his way through the audition
to get the part
unfortunately during production he spent
much of his time clashing with bond
producer cubby broccoli which soured his
experience
nonetheless lazenby was offered a
million dollar contract for six more
movies but his agent convinced him not
to take it for two reasons
first he believed that spy characters
like bond were on their way out
second he believed it wouldn't be hard
for his client to find more million
dollar roles
and then my manager was telling me that
james bond was over
that you know it was make peace not love
not lazenby announced that he was
stepping down from the part before on
her majesty's secret service even
premiered
he went on to act in minor roles but he
never landed any of those big parts his
agent forecasted in 2017 he told usa
today
i'm glad i didn't do another bond
because i would have been totally
trapped in the film industry and i
wouldn't have had the life i had
i wouldn't have had the kids i had i'm
quite satisfied with the way my life has
turned out so far
while you might not recognize the name
peter ostrom you almost certainly know
his face
as a teenager he played charlie bucket
the beating heart of 1971's willy wonka
and the chocolate factory
i think hope i just won more my grandpa
joe
he performed the role with so much
curiosity and joy that we're still
talking about it today
alas though he never cashed that golden
ticket in for long-lasting stardom
instead he disappeared for a while
which is just how he wanted it after
willy wonka ostrom was offered a
three-picture deal but he turned it down
and eventually left acting behind
inspired by a veterinarian who took care
of his family's horse
he decided to become a vet himself he
got his degree from cornell university
and he works as a large animal
veterinarian in upstate new york to this
day
am i famous in my eyes absolutely not
and i'm
amused that everybody's here to talk to
me
and amazed ostrom has been reluctant to
talk about playing charlie for years
he didn't even tell his future wife that
he was in the movie until she was about
to meet his parents but around 1990 he
started going to a local school one day
a year to answer questions from kids
he also opened up publicly in 2005 when
tim burton's charlie and the chocolate
factory was released
and he's since taken part in several
willy wonka related promos and
screenings
jennifer gray had a small but memorable
role as the sister of the title
character in 1986's ferris bueller's day
off before starring as francis baby
houseman the following year in dirty
dancing
that role earned her fame acclaim and a
golden globe nomination but it's
impossible to talk about gray's rise
without also talking about her
subsequent fall while her co-star
patrick swayze's star only grew
gray hit a wall in 1990 she got a nose
job to remove a visible bump this
drastically changed her appearance and
without that distinctive feature
her roles dried up she called it the
nose job from hell and once said i went
into the operating room a celebrity and
came out anonymous
gray has gotten plenty of work in the
ensuing years including a recurring role
as herself in the late 90s sitcom
it's like you know but she's yet to land
another big role
she's still grateful for her part in
dirty dancing and the joy it brings
people but that doesn't mean it's not
repetitive at an anniversary event for
the film she joked i wish anytime i went
into a nice restaurant and asked for a
table they said well i'm
sure you don't want one in the corner
nobody puts baby in a corner
avery brooks played benjamin cisco on
all seven seasons of star trek deep
space nine
going from the commander of a backwater
post to a man on par with any admiral in
starfleet though it was never quite the
ratings hit as the next generation or
voyager
deep space nine is now regarded as one
of the best trek series cisco was unique
among star trek leads besides being the
first black lead character
he was more emotional and a more obvious
misfit than the average starfleet
officer
brook stands in stark contrast to his
fellow star trek captains and commanders
while most remain active in showbiz to
this day he stepped away from the
limelight as he took some time to raise
his daughters and became a professor at
rutgers university
he's taken on similar movie roles but he
primarily performs in theater he never
landed a big on-screen role again but he
doesn't seem to want one
and he doesn't give many interviews
though by all accounts he seems happy
with where his life is now
the wires proposition joe as played by
robert f chu
stood in stark contrast to the show's
other drug lords he was far more relaxed
verbose and manipulative he was also one
of the show's more sympathetic
characters despite ostensibly being one
of the bad guys he's one of just a
handful of street level characters who
appeared in all five seasons but after
the wire ended
chu only had two minor movie parts and
disappeared from public view
entirely by his own choice he lived his
whole life in baltimore the city where
the wire took place
he was born there he went to college
there and he died there he was a fixture
of the charm cities theater scene for a
few decades he also found time for some
tv work including small parts on wire
creator david simon's previous shows
homicide life on the street and the
corner
during his time on the wire he taught
acting at the arena players youth
theater in fact he got 22 of his
students roles on the show and he
coached many of the series new and
inexperienced actors
after the show concluded chu could have
moved to new york or los angeles and
found even greater success in hollywood
instead he stayed in baltimore and
continued to teach acting the city was
too important to him and he stayed there
and helped people hone their craft until
his death in january 2013.
in the early 90s eric de rey played leo
johnson
the first true villain of twin peaks as
an abusive husband
and the most obvious suspect in the
death of laura palmer leo terrified the
town and had every member of the
audience waiting for his comeuppance
i don't know he's the obvious one deray
could have had a long career in show
business
after twin peaks instead he vanished and
it's not entirely clear why he was born
into a showbiz family his father aldo
ray was a go-to tough guy actor for
decades and his mother joanna ray is a
casting director who's worked
extensively with david lynch the creator
of twin peaks after twin peaks was
cancelled deray spent years playing
smaller roles and obscure movies before
outright vanishing from hollywood around
2002.
he hasn't made a movie since then and he
rarely makes public appearances
in 2012 he did briefly resurface though
when he was wrongfully suspected of
starting fires in los angeles
zach galligan burst onto the scene in
1984 as billy peltzer in the hit movie
gremlins his performance proved his
value as a young actor with plenty of
potential
but despite that massive early success
he's done little of note since then
gallagher knew early on that executive
producer steven spielberg's involvement
meant the movie would be a hit an
assumption that proved to be correct
within three weeks of release he was
recognized worldwide everywhere from
local restaurants all the way to south
africa
after gremlins gallaghan went to college
at columbia university
after school he moved back to los
angeles hoping to restart his acting
career but those four years away had
really sapped his momentum he narrowly
missed getting cast in such movies as
saint elmo's fire the rocketeer
and platoon he was able to reprise the
part of billy in 1990s gremlins 2 the
new batch
which bombed in its original release but
has since become a cult classic
he spent his time since then still
acting as well as writing and teaching
acting he's never quite found that next
big role but given how his life has
turned out he thinks that may
actually have been for the best dan
lloyd was unforgettable as little danny
torrance in the 1980 horror classic the
shiner though he never found the role
all that scary
audiences may jump at danny riding his
bike up to those creepy twins but off
screen he played games with the actual
twins between takes
come and play with us even when lloyd
watched the movie years later he wasn't
horrified
instead he was reminded of all the fun
he had on set it was his one big role
before disappearing from show business
but don't worry about him as he's doing
just fine
lloyd tried out for a few more roles
after the shining but he had trouble
landing anything so he just left the
business entirely he now teaches biology
at a community college in kentucky where
he learned the hard way not to tell his
students about his past
lest they disrupt class with chance of
red rum he doesn't give many interviews
about his acting days though he has
revealed that he loved it then and he's
happy with his life now and in 2019 he
had a cameo in the shining
sequel dr sleep check out one of our
newest videos right here plus more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you